okay so uh you have to use all your
aspects right
you can't you can't be going there and
then
oh crap um so when you're doing cookie
nugget
you can change it a lot a lot of degrees
do you see that
so depending on let's say let's say he's
he's behind me right i'm going to move
this guy
between us by taking more
degrees on the rotation right um
second element you can do so instead of
moving
this way you want to try to stack them
so you're gonna go this this way okay
uh the only time you're not going to do
that is when you can't do that
so he's he's going to surround me i
don't want to give my back to that guy
that that's where you're giving me
you're up here
okay and uh
so watch how i'm going to try to stack
them
um i'm going to use all the degrees of
the
cooking on yet and then also you don't
have to throw everyone you might not
have time for the throat
okay and then watch how
you can play with the timing of the
throw so for example
if he's if he's way here and he's
way behind him to go
and throw him very fast and now he comes
in
that this dude's gonna get up and he's
not you're not in the same place
okay so we'll do the same thing
you can play with the timing of the move
so the other guy's coming in and i'm
done here
so i have the degree of rotation the
timing of the move
which also could be like they're really
close and we come in
and it's just quick quick
so
so play with all those things if it's
too routine i do use